ils traversent la frontière à pied
les snowbirds rentrent au pays
différemment cette année linde en ville
et guide a ou non quitter leur fleury
d'adoption en avion en passant par
plattsburgh pour éviter la quarantaine à
l'hôtel le palais dans une chambre
d'hôtel maintenant quelques jours
enfermée ça ne m'intéressait pas du tout
donc à vanneaux d'alternative ce n'est
pas cette rs car les voyageurs qui
rentrent par voie terrestre sont soumis
à une quarantaine mais pas celle de
trois jours à l'hôtel on s'est informée
on a appelé sipson jeandupeux de trouver
un taxi traverser à pied chez le bart et
ils ont l'impression d'avoir fait une
bonne affaire
l'avion a coûté 94 dollars exactement et
l'hôtel une centaine de dollars
américains naturellement le sens
quelques dollars je sais que si je sors
de toi dehors absolument c'est parfait
c'est une façon légale de contourner la
règle en vigueur qui est vu comme un
coup de pouce pour les entreprises de
transport selon la propriétaire de boeuf
only son mois d'avril est presque
complet l'entreprise américaine
transporte en moyenne 25 clients par
jour à partir de l'aéroport de boos flot
jusqu'à la frontière canadienne
certains taxis traverse même la
frontière puisqu'il s'agit d'un service
essentiel
ils ont le droit de le faire plusieurs
transporteurs québécois nous ont
confirmé que ses services sont
particulièrement en demande
sans vouloir accorder d'entrevue le
bureau du ministre de la sécurité
publique rappelle que les voyages non
essentiels sont interdits et que toute
personne entrant au canada doit 6 l île
pendant 14 jours et c'est ce que l'aîné
guy vont faire mais chez eux
issigeac oudry charbonneau radio canada
mon rêve